dominique terrier étudie en génie
industriel à l'université polytechnique
à montréal même si le gouvernement du
québec propose ses recommandations en
matière de santé et sécurité
elle estime que les restaurateurs sont
mal outillés pour rouvrir leur commerce
j'ai vu qu'il n'était pas beaucoup
chapeau t il manqué d'information est un
peu inquiet par rapport à la situation
on s'est dit que ça serait pertinent
d'aller les arrivées c'est pourquoi elle
et ses collègues ont décidé d'ouvrir
gratuitement des services de
consultation aux restaurateurs pour
plusieurs le port de la visière du
masque ou le réaménagement des salles à
manger dans le respect des règles
sanitaires
c'est une tâche qui est très difficile à
appliquer 28 zones où il fait 35 degrés
parce qu'une canicule d'or la visière
avec un mass au dessus d'un chaleureux
qui brouillent pas c'est un peu
ordinaire faki fallait définir ces
enjeux là éric bélanger possède quatre
restaurants à montréal selon lui ces
services conseils pour éviter plusieurs
semaines de casse-tête du côté des
restaurateurs d'une grosse job de bras
en guise mais qui a été fait et avec le
comité qui essuient vrai mais je pense
qu'ils vont réussir la passe à travers
toute une série de questions qui nous
ont pris plusieurs semaines
g
s'arrêter qu'au delà lille propriétaire
du restaurant biblique au qui a ouvert
depuis un an dans le quartier mile end
dernier en fait de valider
beaucoup de questions a beaucoup de
doute qu'on avait ça nous a fait citer
en fait d'ouverture du commerce
dans une étape cruciale de son
développement le petit restaurant doit à
la fois réorganiser son établissement
mais aussi tenter de survivre
financièrement d'ici la fin de l'année
il mise entre autres sur la livraison
pour arrondir ses fins de mois
il faut rester optimiste c'est la seule
façon de pouvoir
le comité étudiant poursuivra ses
activités même à l'automne ici gabriel
proulx radio canada montréal